I think this is the right time you know
people are saying but your sentencing is
coming up in a couple weeks and that's
not the other thing and that is true and
I'm really nervous about that more than
the surgery but there's no right time
only et is with former Dance Moms star
Abby Lee Miller for her weight loss
surgery I thought you know what maybe
this is some miraculous way that
somebody's telling me hey go for it do
it now so that whatever happens maybe
you'll be a little bit healthier
maybe you'll be a little bit more in
shape who nuts
the 50 year old reality star opened up
about her attempts to eat healthy she's
even tried a vegan diet in the past but
she claims she got no support from the
Dance Moms production they would laugh
in my face they didn't care if I was
trying to be vegan they wouldn't get a
special vegan meal or anything they just
laughed in Hania hoagie sandwich like
that Italian sub from somewhere and I'm
like what is this lunch meat I get this
it's been a rough few months for Miller
she's awaiting sentencing after pleading
guilty to bankruptcy fraud last June and
she dramatically quit her long-running
life time series in March Miller says
she currently has no plans to return to
the show I would love to go back but it
would have to change you know there has
to be a sense of respect there has to be
a creative credit to hear more about
Abby Lee Miller surgery and her upcoming
projects tune into et Monday April 24th
you